I've been assured by people that the
third season does get better again and I
hope they're right because otherwise I'm
gonna have to re-evaluate some
friendships orphan black season 2 you
know there's no timeliness to this at
all but I did a review of the first
season of orphan black after I finish it
I feel like doing one of the second
season and oh boy I'm not giving up on
the show because the first season was
better so I know the show can be better
than what i got in this season and there
are good things about it still it's not
a complete everything went down the
drain but there's a lot of problems in
this season but let's start out positive
what did I like well surprisingly some
of the stuff that I didn't like last
season for instance Alison I love her
and this I don't know if it's just more
time with her and she's grown on me but
I just I love her neuro season yet she's
able to sort of take a breath and just
tackle the immediate situation I love
Donny at this point I think he's turning
into a really interesting character
while I wasn't thrilled that dr. leekie
exited the show because as I mentioned
last season I really love matt frewer
the way that he exited was brilliant I
now really like Elena who I also didn't
like last season she's used so much
better this time she's now kind of
functioning almost a little bit as an
all-purpose wildcard and I think that
sutures so much better than just being a
tool of the villains we also get Cal who
I like I bat how mostly just chalk up to
charisma the guy's just a really likable
actor he works very well rachel is a
terrific villain what I especially love
about her is that you know she's all
business or at least that's her
appearance she's like it's just business
it's not personal but we see through
season just the performance oh it's
deeply personal it's really really
personal for her and I like that
contrast that someone who's going to say
this is not personal but it is that just
makes a more interesting deeper villain
and some of the stuff that was good last
season remains good mrs. s is still good
felix is still good Vic I was shocked
that I was happy when Vic showed up a
is this a character that I should be
annoyed when he shows up again he he
should just be an imitation I'll we're
still dealing with this guy but again
I'm gonna chalk it up to the actor he's
just fun and energetic and charismatic
and he brings a great feeling and flavor
to Boonton whatever episodes he's in so
I was happy to see him back and I think
they used him in just the right amount
all of that having been said there's a
lot of problems with this season overall
I guess we'll start with the proletheans
now I've got a lot of issues with this
they're just first of all they're
generic as heck because we never get to
understand what their belief system is I
mean there's these very vague references
to the work of God and Helene is a
miracle but why do they think that why
are they interested in her heck scratch
that why is anybody interested in the
clones at all this seems to be way
deeper than just this idea of oh this is
revolutionary technology or
revolutionary science we should continue
this everybody they act like they've got
some deeper agenda but we don't want to
know what any of them are and that was
intriguing in the first season at this
point I at least one of them it would
have been nice to get an answer for how
many friggin factions there are because
there's dyad and there's a splinter
within that you can practically carve
that into two halves in the first place
there's the proletheans there's whoever
the heck mrs. s is aligned with at the
very end we get the this notion that
there's a military angle I mean all
these people want the clones and we
still don't really know why but getting
back to the proletheans specifically
their their religion aspect is so
generic obviously probably in an effort
to not offend anyone to not get specific
what I mean you're obviously making it
up you gave it a made-up name so give me
some details for what it is what makes
them unique because you just outwardly
you made them very kind of Christian
cultish but I don't know if that was
supposed to be just a general insert
Christian cult here thing but I mean
think they're just not interesting it
was like the knee Aleutians last season
that was the least interesting part of
that season but the proletheans are just
as uninteresting but eat up way more
time art is painfully underused in this
season because he was one of the
highlights last use and we barely see
him this city's and instead we spend
this time with his partner who just
just grating in terms of both what she
is doing and which does not add anything
to the story and just her personality
I'm like you're annoying go away I don't
like you Cosima Cosima at this point
annoys me she was a little bit that she
basically wrote neutral for me in the
first season I didn't jump on board with
her and at this point I now actively
disliked her because I feel like the
makers of the show knew who their
audience was gonna be in that the
audience for this kind of show this kind
of sci-fi bent was going to be kind of
geeky so they just gave her a couple of
geeky aspect so she's sciency and she's
into whatever this made-up version of
D&D is don't you love her well no
because you haven't really characterized
her beyond these very broad strokes
she's there for exposition and to just
try and be a geek crush but there's very
little death to her oh and let's not
forget her plot convenient itís this
wonderful disease that gets worse
whenever it's going to move the plot
along and then gets better when we want
to focus on other things it's just it's
contrived lazy writing and especially
when I look at someone like Alison and
how much the show has worked to
characterize her and give her all these
layers and give all these deficit and
put in all this work so that I did grow
to like her and I feel like none of that
kind of work was done with Cosima they
just gave her a few characteristics that
they figured would be very favorable to
the audience that this is intended for
and left it at that and you know what I
don't care i was actually annoyed when
she turned out not to die in the last
episode of this season i would rather
she have died because i don't feel like
she's contributing anything other than
exposition and the occasional plot
motivator but there's another thing that
links into this and this links into
something else and that has to do with
her being a lesbian now I brought that
up briefly last season but I didn't
bring up the thing about it that
actually bothered me kind of actively
because I was prepared to just let it go
and not make a thing out of it but
thanks to the introduction of tony who
first of all is pointless he shows up he
does nothing he vanishes what was the
point of him but even beyond that the
implications of that character I
actually have a big problem with now
for I go on this little mini rant I will
preface this and saying the subtext I'm
about to talk about I do not believe to
be intentional I do not believe to be
deliberate and I do not believe to be
hateful in any way however I do believe
that subtext is still there whether they
meant to do it or not and it's
problematic for me what that subtext is
is all these clones they are genetically
identical so that means whatever
differences there are between them is
down to how they will raise their
upbringing their experiences their
nurturing so what that means is if
Cosima is gay then the only thing making
her gay is whatever her experiences and
since we've had absolutely no indication
of even been by tendencies in any of the
other clones that means that the show is
saying again probably unintentionally
but it's saying that being gay is a
choice and it is not it does not run
deeper than that because if it did it
shouldn't have just been one of them now
as I said I was prepared to let that go
last season because I'm like Ed they
probably thought it was just a cute idea
that one of them me gay this is not
intentional let it go but now they've
done it with a trans character in
addition to a lesbian character because
again tony is genetically identical to
all the rest of them and yet goes down
this path and I'm not trying to get into
that debate of whether being trans or
being gay is something you're born with
or something that is raised by a nursery
I mean let's be honest most of the
science points to that there is
something inherent in you and it's not
just how you were raised meaning it's
not a choice but regardless of where you
fall in that debate the fact remains
that the idea that being trans are being
lesbian is a choice is a notion that has
been the backbone for people making
arguments that are rooted in the
intention to oppress these people saying
you're just choosing to do that is a big
part of what gets people who want to
undermine them and deny them rights
that's a big part of their argument a
lot of the time and that makes this a
problem because the only way it makes
sense that one of the clones ends up
trans and another one ends up game the
rest don't is that well it's a choice
because if it was down to genetics it
shouldn't just be these two this is
really
matic for me as a viewer and again I
don't think they did it on purpose but
once is a fluke twice as a pattern at
best they're just not paying enough
attention to what the things that
they're putting in the show imply and I
might have been able to let it go if
Tony had been a meeting for character
but as I said eat eat serves no function
whatsoever at least as we saw him in
this season I mean maybe he'll come back
and be important next season but if that
ends up being the case just introduce
the next season don't have him show up
here and do nothing the last thing I
gotta go off on is basically the last
episode last episode drove me crazy
because there was a lot of very stupid
stuff well actually even in the lead up
to the last time so there's some very
stupid things that happen when I say
stupid I don't necessarily mean plot
developments I mean characters do
incredibly stupid things I'm gonna start
with Sarah who is not my favorite clone
anymore be partly because Alison now
occupies that spot but also because of
what I'm about to talk about which is
that Sarah is actually pushing for Kira
to donate the bone marrow to save Cosima
now I understand Sarah wants to save
Cosima but it's her daughter she's known
this clone woman for I don't know what
the timeline is at this point but it's
it can't have been more than a few
months and she's pushing to put her
daughter at risk to save her no it
doesn't work what should have happened
was Sarah should have been saying what
mrs. s was saying which is that any risk
to Cara is too much but then other
characters go why don't you ask her what
she wants and then Kyra saying mommy I
want to do this I want to help save her
and then that would have Sarah be well I
can't say no to you if this is what you
want to do because you'll hate me if I
don't let you do this that would have
worked in order to find would have been
consistent with the characters but the
fact that mrs. s was the one who had to
be making that argument and Sarah was
pushing basically pushing to endanger
her daughter no that's not okay that's
really dumb and it's made worse by the
fact that they stay in the same hospital
that the operation happens in for her to
recover they Diane knows where you are
they had someone there picking up the
stuff leave don't stay there and that's
the kind of really stupid stuff that
happens in the final stretch of this
episode there's the character of Duncan
who I actually really like i like this
guy a lot but the way that he was closed
out and the way that he died was just
really stupid and I don't meet the fact
that he committed suicide i buy that
that's fine it works with the character
as I understood him no problem with that
but here's the thing he's at this point
he is a prisoner it's not one of those
sort of you knows villain kind of
cliches was like oh you're my guest but
I'm just not gonna let you leave no he's
obviously prisoner they took away his
normal clothes put him in prison her
clothes and yet they let him keep his
specialty who they is the head of
security at diet because they need to be
fired right now and on that same note
are you telling me that Cosima who is a
clone she is part of this project and
diet no she has been in contact with
other clones some of whom they are
actively trying to pursue there's no
security cameras in the lab that she's
in to monitor what she's doing and she
can and she and that other guy can just
make a friggin pencils gun and nobody is
paying any attention to what's going on
in that lab and finally the final straw
of stupidity after Sarah escapes and
Cosima sneaks out of dyad and they know
that Rachel and all the other people are
gonna be pissed and looking for them
where do they hole up Felix's apartment
dyad knows about Felix and they know
where he lives everybody who's after
them knows who Felix's and they know
where he lives and it's not even like
they stopped off there to get supplies
to go off somewhere safe or they spend
the night there I'm stunned that
Helena's the only one who got grabbed
and then there's the final twist at the
end which just has no meaning for me
again because I don't know enough about
why the clones exist in the first place
or why everyone wants them so this idea
that you're going there's another batch
of clones I'm like I still don't know
what the first batch was for so that
doesn't mean anything to me just a lot
of
dumb stuff a lot of stuff dragging the
season down stuff that wasn't
interesting stuff that was unnecessary
stuff that was just stupid there's still
things are working all the stuff that I
talked about at the front end you know
the first season was good so I'm gonna
come back and watch the third season and
hopefully catch up on that before the
fourth season starts airing but man I
tell you if this second season had been
the first I wouldn't have kept watching
so yeah that's uh that this was not
particularly fun so second season of
orphan black i am now through it i'll
get started on the third season as soon
as i'm able to have you seen all the
second season for from black what were
your thoughts on it whatever they were
drop something down in the comments and
let's talk about it until next time this
council is adjourned